Bonjour!
Comme promis après vous avoir parlé de la
mer, on va aborder aujourd'hui les relations
entre les hommes et un autre élément naturel:
la forêt!
Cet épisode a été à la base écrit pour
une conférence, que j'ai donnée cet été
lors des médiévales fantastiques de Mormal.
-L'épisode de la flemme, en quelque sorte.
-L'épisode où je n'avais pas envie que le
fruit de mes longues recherches soit perdu
dans une unique conférence non filmée. J'te
permet pas.
Comme la conférence se passait dans la forêt
de Mormal, on gardera aussi cette forêt comme
exemple parce qu'elle est jolie et qu'il y
a pas mal de choses à dire dessus.
Et comme avec la mer on va largement déborder
du Moyen Âge, déso Aliénor, parce que l'histoire
des forêts ne commence pas au Ve siècle
et ne se termine pas en 1492, ou quelles que
soient les dates limites du MA.
-Y'a des limites au MA?!
-Bref c'est parti pour les forêts et comme
dirait Jamy: on a du bouleau! Bouleau,
l'arbre...
Les forêts sont habitées depuis très longtemps,
même s'il paraît difficile de retrouver
des traces de ces habitations vu tous les
changements qu'elles ont subi depuis.
Et pourtant, grâce à l'archéologie, on
retrouve parfois des petites déformations
de terrain ou encore des plantes comme la
sauge, les céréales, les groseilles à maquereau
qui montrent que les hommes ont aménagé
et cultivé la forêt dès la préhistoire.
La forêt de Mormal, par exemple, est bordée
par une ancienne voie romaine à l'ouest,
la voie Agrippa, qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
la chaussée Brunehaut. Durant l'époque gallo-romaine,
la forêt était déjà habitée puisqu'on
y trouve de petites huttes en bois.
-Ah, c'était ça, le passage où on mentionnait
mon époque? A se demander ce que je fais
encore ici...
Pour aménager la forêt, on passe souvent
par des déboisements. Vivre en plein milieu
des bois c'est beau mais peu pratique, alors
il ne faut pas croire que la France a toujours
été un pays recouvert d'arbres: de nos
jours il y a environ 15 millions d'hectares
de forêt en France, et c'est plus qu'au XIIIe
siècle!
A Mormal, les noms des villages et hameaux
qu'on trouve autour de la forêt, les Grands
Chênes, le Rond Quesne, le Grand Sart, le
Sart Bara... Nous montrent que la forêt a
effectivement été défrichée au MA pour
créer de nouveaux villages. Ces défrichements
ont lieu très tôt, puisque la plupart des
hameaux autour de la forêt apparaissent entre
le Ve et le XIIe siècle au plus tard.
Les déboisements deviennent très importants
à partir du XIe siècle, parce que les seigneurs
encouragent la création de nouveaux villages.
On retrouve une preuve de ces déboisements
dans les noms des villes.
-Villeneuve-le-Comte, par exemple, qui semble
montrer qu'un comte a décidé de créer une
nouvelle ville.
-Ou encore toutes les villes qui s'appellent
Essarts, Esserts, puisque ça désigne une
terre défrichée.
Il y a aussi énormément de villes en France
dont le nom est inspiré des arbres qu'on
trouvait dans le coin, souvent des châtaigniers
ou des frênes. Fresnes sur Escaut, par exemple,
pour rester dans les environs de chez moi.
Au cours de l'époque moderne on continue
de déboiser les forêts, parce qu'on verra
plus tard que le bois ne sert pas qu'à laisser
la place à des villages. Et tout ça fait
qu'au début du XIXe siècle, la France a
deux fois moins de surface forestière qu'aujourd'hui,
et c'est seulement à cette époque que les
forêts commencent à regagner du terrain.
-Genre les forêts avancent toutes seules.
Attends, non, tu vas pas encore faire une
référence pop cult...
-La première raison de ce retour de la forêt
est que de plus en plus de gens partent vivre
en ville, vous avez sûrement déjà entendu
parler de l'exode rural: eh ben là, on
est en plein dedans, et ça fait que beaucoup
d'espaces ruraux se retrouvent abandonnés:
les montagnes, par exemple, où on trouvait
beaucoup de bergers jusqu'au XIXe mais faute
de vaches ou de moutons à faire pâturer,
la forêt revient.
Pourtant, que la montagne est belle.
L'élevage de poissons dans des étangs diminue
aussi: encore des espaces qui se retrouvent
abandonnés et donc où les arbres repoussent.
Et parfois, les reboisements sont volontaires:
l'exemple le plus marquant est la forêt des
landes, qui était auparavant une grande région
de marécages où les bergers se déplaçaient
sur des échasses: début XIXe on décide
d'y planter des forêts de pins maritimes,
pour mieux les abattre et en faire du bois
mais aussi pour faire reculer les dunes. Adieu
les bergers, et bonjour la forêt industrielle.
-Ça suffit! Dans les Cévennes et les Hautes-Alpes,
qui étaient presque entièrement déboisées
au XIXe, on replante des arbres pour éviter
les risques d'éboulements ou d'inondations.
-C'est aussi au XIXe que se développent les
organismes pour entretenir et gérer la forêt.
Rien n'est laissé au hasard depuis déjà
longtemps: les grandes allées droites qu'on
trouve dans beaucoup de forêts servent à
la fois à repérer le gibier, pour la chasse,
et à faciliter la gestion du terrain pour
les forestiers. Elles sont tracées au XVIIIe
siècle, époque où on aimait que les forêts
soient bien ordonnées.
On pose aussi des bornes aux angles des parcelles,
dont il reste parfois des traces même si
de nos jours on préfère peindre les arbres
qui marquent ces angles de parcelles.
Et en 1824, on crée l'école nationale des
Eaux et Forêts, à Nancy, d'où sortent les
agents forestiers. Dans cette école ils ont
une éducation quasi militaire et apprennent
entre autres le tir, parce qu'il faut encore
se méfier des braconniers. Après leur formation
ils sont affectés dans une forêt et vivent
dans des maisons forestières dont on garde
aussi des traces aujourd'hui.
D'ailleurs en France on distingue trois types
de forêts:
-Les forêts domaniales, qui sont souvent
issues des forêts seigneurialesdu MA, les
meilleures.
-Les forêts communales qui sont reliées
aux villages à partir de la Révolution,
-Et enfin les forêts privées qui appartiennent
souvent aux bourgeois qui se sont enrichis
au XIXe siècle.
Je fais une coupure qui n'était pas prévue
à la base dans cette vidéo, parce que j'ai
appris d'autres choses depuis l'enregistrement
de l'épisode et que je tenais à vous en
parler.
Dans cette première partie, j'ai l'air de
dire qu'on reboise les forêts depuis le XIXe
siècle et que c'est forcément une bonne
chose. Or ce n'est pas toujours vrai, et si
vous voulez comprendre pourquoi je vous encourage
à regarder le documentaire «Le Temps des
Forêts» qui est sorti au cinéma en septembre.
Il explique les dangers non pas de la déforestation
en France mais de la malforestation: la
forêt est une industrie, l'abattage et la
vente de troncs est son principal fond de
commerce, mais cela encourage de plus en plus
de propriétaires à faire des monoplantations
de l'essence d'arbre qui se vend le plus.
C'est le cas dans les forêts des landes dès
le XIXe siècle, mais aussi dans de très
nombreuses forêts qui voient alors leur faune
disparaître. Les sols deviennent stériles
car l'humus ne peut pas se former, et seule
l'utilisation d'engrais permet à ces arbres
de pousser jusqu'à ce qu'on coupe toute la
parcelle à blanc quand elle a atteint la
bonne taille pour être vendue. Voilà, c'était
le petit point déprime, merci de votre attention
et je vous renvoie au moi du passé qui va
vous parler des activités en forêt et donc
à nouveau d'abattage de troncs. Mais maintenant,
vous savez.
Maintenant qu'on a vu rapidement l'histoire
des déboisements et reboisements, on va pouvoir
se poser la question: à quoi sert une forêt?
-On peut faire plein de choses dans une forêt!
-Déjà, on peut aller cueillir des champignons.
Et ça paraît bête, mais ces types de cueillettes
sont très réglementés: pour les champignons
par exemple, en cueillir sur un terrain qui
ne nous appartient pas est considéré comme
du vol depuis la Révolution.
Pour tous les produits de la forêt, au MA,
la cueillette dépendait de droits accordés
par le seigneur aux paysans, parfois gratuitement,
parfois contre une taxe. Il y avait souvent
des conditions: il fallait que la cueillette
soit pour un usage personnel, que la personne
vive dans le village depuis une année, parfois
plus...
Les gens ramassaient des feuilles mortes pour
faire de l'engrais, des baies, ou encore du
bois mort, et pour ce dernier il faut respecter
des règles très précises:
-Le bois doit être sec, trouvé à terre,
cassé à la main et porté sur son dos, pour
éviter d'en emmener trop d'un coup.
-Jusqu'au début du Xxe siècle, beaucoup
de gens dans les campagnes profitaient encore
de ce droit pour récolter leur bois.
Les habitants d'une seigneurie ont aussi le
droit d'affouage, càd récolter du bois vif,
même si un arbre, c'est pas très vif, et
le droit de faire pâturer leurs porcs dans
la forêt.
Dans la forêt de Mormal on trouve beaucoup
de pâtures, pour les chevaux du comte de
Hainaut, mais beaucoup d'habitants des villages
alentours avaient le droit d'y faire aussi
pâturer leurs vaches et porcs.
-Il existe même une amende de 60 francs,
au début du Xve, si quelqu'un est pris en
train d'abattre un hêtre ou un chêne parce
que les animaux apprécient beaucoup leurs
fruits.
Cependant au cours des Xve, XVIe, XVIIe siècles,
la forêt est très dégradée par les pâturages
beaucoup trop nombreux, à tel point que certaines
ordonnances prévoient des amendes pour les
bêtes trouvées dans la forêt.
En 1535, puis en 1601, le droit de pâture
est carrément supprimé et l'ordonnance déclare
que la forêt "seroit d' icy à quelques années
réduite à néant à cause de la pasture
des bêtes tant chevalines qu'autres...".
Tout ça indique déjà une volonté de préserver
les forêts, mais qui n'est pas toujours très
efficace.
-Autre exemple de fonction de la forêt:
imaginez que vous êtes un moine. Vous installez
votre abbaye près d'une forêt voire carrément
en plein milieu, déjà parce que c'est joli
et suffisamment isolé pour méditer sur le
sens de la vie.
-Mais surtout, y'a plein de travail à tirer
de la forêt, et pour certains ordres religieux,
le travail, c'est sacré. Littéralement du
coup. Certaines abbayes mettent en place des
ateliers de forge, de verrerie... Et donc,
exploitent la forêt.
Au XVe siècle, avec l'invention des hauts
fourneaux à bois, de très nombreux ateliers
choisissent de s'implanter en forêt: des
forges et verreries donc, mais aussi des briqueteries,
des tuileries, des salines... Pour faire fonctionner
ces ateliers il faut des fours, et donc du
charbon de bois. D'où l'intérêt de s'installer
directement en forêt.
Par exemple, la manufacture de Saint-Gobain
s'installe en forêt au XVIIe siècle et consomme
pas loin de 200ha de forêt par an!
Dans les forêts qui possèdent des ateliers,
on plante alors surtout du chêne et du hêtre,
parce qu'ils donnent du meilleur charbon de
bois. Les essences d'arbres qu'on trouve dans
les forêts permettent donc de savoir à quoi
elles ont pu servir.
Dans les régions viticoles on plante plutôt
des châtaigniers, pour fabriquer les piquets
des vignes et des chênes pour les tonneaux...
-Au XVIIe siècle, Louis XIV décide de développer
la Marine, et pour ça évidemment, il faut
du bois: jusque 1900, il y a donc des forêts
qui sont dirigées par des officiers de la
Marine et qui sont exploitées pour la construction
navale.
-A partir du XIXe siècle, on a aussi besoin
de plus en plus de bois pour construire les
galeries des mines et les chemins de fer,
et pour ça on préfère utiliser du pin maritime:
encore une nouvelle espèce plantée en masse.
-D'autres activités un peu moins répandues
existent comme la récolte du tan du chêne,
de l'écorce de chêne-liège pour en faire
des bouchons, même si elle décline à partir
des années 50, ou encore la récolte de la
résine du pin des landes à partir du XIXe
siècle.
Cette utilisation massive du bois nécessite
forcément d'abattre le bois, et de le transporter
hors de la forêt.
D'abord, quand on abat un arbre, on le transporte
par les chemins forestiers bien droits dont
on parlait plus tôt jusqu'au lieu de débardage,
où on le coupe bien proprement. Ensuite,
pour les longues distances et avant que le
chemin de fer apparaisse, on utilise souvent
les voies d'eau.
Et pour ça on ne va pas s'embêter à construire
un bateau: on balance les bûches dans la
rivière, et elles finiront bien par arriver.
Ça s'appelle le flottage. Pour faciliter
le voyage des bûches, on peut aussi former
des radeau ou encore des trains de bois, qui
formaient des gros convois tout en longueur
avec un pilote debout sur les premières bûches
pour diriger le tout. D'ailleurs le dernier
convoi de bois de ce genre arrive à Paris
en 1923, ce qui est sûrement plus tard que
ce que vous imaginiez.
Il existait une pratique encore plus marrante
dans les Vosges qui s'appelle le schlittage,
et qui consistait à transporter le bois sous
forme de luge, parce que c'est toujours bien
de joindre l'utile à l'agréable.
Malheureusement à partir du XIXe siècle,
avec le développement du chemin de fer, de
l'industrie et du charbon issu des mines,
nos petits ateliers forestiers ont tendance
à disparaître et le charbon de bois aussi.
Tous ces charmants métiers de schlitteur,
à vos souhaits, radeleur, flotteur de bûches
et autres vendeurs de fagots disparaissent
progressivement ou deviennent des éléments
du folklore.
Mais la forêt, c'est aussi un lieu où on
s'enjaille, on s'encanaille, on s'amuse!
Et pour ça le plus vieux loisir qu'on peut
pratiquer en forêt est la chasse. D'accord,
avant, c'était plutôt une nécessité pour
les gens, mais ici on parle de la chasse de
luxe, pratiquée par les seigneurs, la noblesse,
Macron, et ses amis, et donc elle nécessite
de tailler un peu dans les forêts sinon c'est
pas drôle.
Déjà, je vous ai parlé des grandes routes
droites qu'on traçait à travers les bois.
Eh ben ça sert aussi pour la chasse, parce
que comme ça on n'a qu'à se planter à un
croisement et attendre de voir quelle route
le gibier va traverser.
A partir du XVIIe siècle, dans les grandes
forêts royales comme Versailles ou Chambord,
on entoure carrément les forêts de murs
pour ne laisser aucune chance aux gibiers
de sortir.
-Ça plaît pas trop aux populations locales
qui, du coup, n'ont plus aucune chance de
rentrer non plus. Sauf en y faisant des brèches,
et c'est ce qui se passe rapidement.
-Et à partir de là, tout est fait pour faciliter
le travail des chasseurs: on installe des
éléments de décor comme des clairières,
des marais, des poteaux pour éviter de se
perdre, et même des tables à débotter pour
monter et descendre de cheval sans trop d'effort.
On creuse aussi des étangs dans des forêts
pour faire des «bat l'eau»: c'est
quand le cerf se retrouve encerclé et se
met à nager au milieu de l'étang pour éviter
les chiens. On s'éclate. J'avais pas envie
d'illustrer cette partie.
Mais comme la chasse devient un loisir de
riche, tout le monde ne va pas se fatiguer
à monter à cheval pour courir les bois:
on trace donc des allées pavées pour amener
le public en calèche, qui pourra pique-niquer
avec tout le monde et assister à la mise
à mort.
Enfin, je vous raconte qu'on facilitait bien
la tâche aux chasseurs au XVIIIe siècle,
mais c'est pas comme si c'était encore le
cas aujourd'hui, hein.
Au XIXe siècle, les forêts s'ouvrent beaucoup
plus au public et surtout à un public qui
aime les forêts, pour ce qu'elles sont, sans
y chercher d'autre usage que s'y promener.
Cette fois on les aménage plutôt avec des
petits sentiers tortueux, des fontaines, des
grottes, des lacs, des restaurants, et surtout
on les rend accessibles: par exemple des
trains relient Paris à Fontainebleau à partir
de 1849.
C'est aussi à cette époque que se créent
des clubs de randonnée, des hôtels près
des forêts et autres joyeusetés, et que
les peintres se mettent à représenter des
tas de paysages de ces forêts. A Fontainebleau
par exemple, c'est une association d'artistes
qui fonde la Commission de Protection artistique
de Fontainebleau dans les années 1850 pour
la protéger de l'exploitation et pouvoir
continuer à la peindre.
Et maintenant on repart dans le passé, parce
que les forêts sont aussi des lieux symboliques,
mystiques, qui parlent à notre imaginaire.
Déjà, les forêts sont très souvent reliées
aux religions, qu'elles soient scandinaves
avec l'arbre-monde ou plus occidentales. Pour
ce qui est de la version scandinave, je vous
renvoie à ma vidéo sur l'Yggdrasil.
Toutes ces croyances se retrouvent dans les
traditions issues des cultes païens, avec
par exemple les «arbres à loques» où
on pend le vêtement d'une personne malade
pour la guérir, tradition ancienne qui persiste
encore aujourd'hui. Dans le même registre
on trouve les «arbres à clou» où on
plante un clou pour transmettre la maladie
à l'arbre.
Avec l'arrivée du christianisme, on tente
de remplacer ces traditions en installant
des chapelles ou des lieux saints...
-Dans les forêts, justement, là où avaient
lieu les cultes païens. Ou bien juste au
bord.
Des ermites ou des saints s'installent aussi
dans les forêts, pour veiller sur ces lieux
ou juste pour se retirer de la civilisation,
et sont à l'origine de pas mal de légendes
locales.
Puisqu'on parle de légendes, les forêts
sont certainement les lieux qui en véhiculent
le plus: forcément, au MA ce sont des lieux
de passage dans lesquels on n'aime pas trop
s'attarder, alors le moindre craquement a
tendance à faire penser à des fées, diables,
feux follets ou autres créatures. Ces légendes
sont surtout amplifiées au XIXe siècle,
mais on les retrouve bien avant.
Par exemple, dans la forêt de Verzy en Champagne,
on trouve des troncs sinueux appelés faux
qui auraient pour origine la malédiction
qui aurait frappé un moine de Reims après
qu'il ait étreint une jeune fille qui s'avérait
être un démon, ce qui aurait donné naissance
à des diablotins qui se seraient transformés
en ces faux.
Le bois de Dardennes serait, selon la légende,
ce qui reste de la forêt de Scissy qu'un
raz de marée aurait englouti au VIIIe siècle,
donnant naissance au mont Saint Michel. Rien
ne prouve ce mythe.
Et bien sûr, il y a les légendes Arthuriennes
et la forêt de Brocéliande.
Souvent la forêt angoisse, comme dans Blanche
Neige, le Petit Poucet où les enfants sont
conduits dans la forêt pour y mourir. On
peut y rencontrer des ogres ou des dangers
plus réels, comme le loup qui tuait encore
souvent au XVIIe siècle, ou le bandit.
Dans beaucoup d'histoires la forêt reste
un lieu interdit car dangereux, et là forcément
ça nous évoque la forêt interdite la plus
connue et fréquentée du cinéma.
Ou bien, c'est un lieu de passage, et le personnage
qui parvient à en sortir devient un héros,
comme dans la Belle au Bois Dormant.
Toutes ces idées reçues sur les forêts
peuvent facilement se comprendre si on reprend
l'exemple de la forêt de Mormal:
Jusqu'au XIXe siècle, la forêt était aussi
une frontière naturelle: elle abritait
quelques brigands et constituait une cloison
entre le pays de l'Escaut et de la Sambre,
puisqu'on ne pouvait pas la traverser facilement.
Les quelques chemins forestiers hérités
du MA, les chevauchoires, étaient souvent
humides, impraticables, et en plus il fallait
payer un péage pour le comte de Hainaut pour
traverser la forêt. -La libre traversée
est autorisée en 1607 mais les chemins restent
impraticables en voiture, surtout en hiver.
-Ce n'est qu'en 1839 que des chemins publics
de qualité sont creusés à travers la forêt,
puis une voie ferrée: avant ça, il fallait
faire un long détour pour en atteindre l'autre
côté, ou ne pas essayer de l'atteindre du
tout puisque les populations locales étaient
assez casanières, faute de pouvoir voyager
facilement. On comprend mieux pourquoi traverser
une forêt était vu comme un exploit dans
de nombreux contes.
Ce n'est qu'à partir du XVIIIe siècle que
la forêt commence à devenir un lieu agréable
dans l'imaginaire et chez les auteurs, et
même un lieu d'enchantement et de bien-être.
Comme les décrit Victor Hugo:
«Là se penchent rêveurs les grands pins,
les grands ormes
Dont les rameaux font cent coudes difformes
Et dans ce groupe sombre agité par le vent
Rien n'est tout à fait mort ni tout à fait
vivant.»
J'espère vous avoir fait un peu voyager.
J'espère que comme moi vous allez avoir envie
de regarder autour de vous la prochaine fois
que vous vous trouverez dans les bois, et
de vous imaginer toutes les personnes qui
ont traversé, habité ou dépendu de ces
forêts pour vivre.
En attendant, on se dit à bientôt pour un
épisode beaucoup plus sombre, Halloween oblige,
et...
-Partagez, commentez et allez sur Utip ou
Tipeee si vous voulez me soutenir.
-On le dit pas à chaque fois, ça, Aliénor!
C'est énervant pour les gens!
-Ah. Euh...
-Abonnez-vous!